it's great to be joined today by vincent
hendricks who's the author of info
storms available a bit later this week
and founder of the Center for
information and bubble studies joining
me today I believe from Copenhagen
Denmark is that right indeed David
indeed so I I'm super interested in the
way in which technology is sort of
shaping the way that even even as humans
as Homo sapiens we are taking in
information and I'd I'd love to just
very generally since this is an area of
your expertise open it up to you for
people who maybe haven't considered this
give us some examples of how modern
technology is really allowing humans to
take in information in a very different
way than what's been the norm in human
history well information is no longer a
scarcity that's one thing we got enough
of right so the information is
information age has brought us vast
amount of information but as Mission
Kapoor who started Lotus development
group once said you know getting
information off the web is like taking a
drink from a fire hydrant so once you
open it up it just basically starts
pouring and so the issue is I'll be
properly curating the information that
you're using and why is information and
important to us well it's important to
us because information is something to
be used to act deliberate and dis
consider things you buy and so from that
perspective it's extremely Center
central to us as human beings just
basically to navigate in the world that
we have information but the problem with
information per se is information
doesn't have to be truthful so rumor is
for instance well you could run with a
rumor you might even act on a certain
rumor but it doesn't necessarily mean
that this particular rumor has anything
to do with the truth and humans are sort
of suckers to the truth it's important
to us because that's basically the
information that we really want to make
our decisions based upon so there are
many examples where rumors or here says
or hoaxes online may actually get
amplified to proportions that you never
see so waitin to 23 it let me pause
there and say I agree with everything
you're saying but
me push back in one way which is I'm not
hearing anything that is unique due to
modern technology in a particular sense
I don't know if you read James gleich
book the information and in it he has
this great example where he says you
know when you think about it all of the
sort of potential pitfalls of
information that exists today adjusted
for better technology existed at the at
the beginning of mankind for example
when when we had different tribes
communicate with each other over long
distances with drums were a
predetermined message a drumming pattern
would communicate uh safety or danger
there's food here or there's no food
here whatever even back then you could
have that communication spoofed by
someone wishing to send a tribe the
wrong message and you have that
communication sort of intercepted in the
way that the NSA can intercept today so
have are we talking about different
equipment or or have has anything
fundamentally changed well I mean so all
these all the pitfalls have you had
before we still have those the only
thing is that the information age the
internet social media and other things I
actually able to amplify certain
phenomena beyond proportions that we
have every portion have you ever seen
before so say like lemming effects where
everybody is thinking the same thing
about the same thing because apparently
everybody else is doing so pluralistic
ignorance where we believe that
everybody believes because that's what
we think that our immediate surroundings
will think so basically what I'm trying
to say is that is not like we're talking
about particularly new phenomena yeah
but what we are talking about is a dose
particular phenomena that could derail
reason and rationality have been
amplified beyond things that we have
ever never seen before and in on global
reach and at the speed of light and
those phenomena are sort of new in so
far as to say the amplification we have
never seen to this extent nor can be say
that we have seen rumor has been able to
go global world by dead center etc and
actually have repercussions in many
different parts of the world
what way way away from where they were
actually started up so plans days you
can crash stock markets with a rumor
that started one place and ended up in
another place from that perspective no
you're right these things not new but
they amplify to proportions never seen
before so this gets me into something
I'm super interested in which is also an
area that that you really concentrate
which is uh considering what should a
more modern approach to sort of
epistemology justifying our beliefs
understanding how to interpret
information and distinguish in order to
sort of at the micro level not fall
victim to hoaxes and rumors as you say
but big picture critical thinking in
sort of the modern age so I would love
it if you could tell it's in in a way
that would maybe appeal both the people
who have done some formal critical
thinking course work but also to people
who haven't what's the best way to
approach justifying our beliefs in the
modern technological age all right so
that's a very good question now of
course of course all the standard
procedures of you already know law
permit system ology are still in play
but what does being said which is
probable alien at least two standard
epistemology is that group thinking and
group reason and Oliver certain is a
very sit and took part in the way we
make the petitions now one of the issues
that we have found and the social
psychology have found in particular for
is that we could be individually
rational but collectively deaths simply
because we actually get to interpret the
signals that we get from others in
unfortunate ways that for instance the
way bystander in sex often happen right
so I see somebody falling I'm in doubt
as to whether or not this person is need
of help so instead of actually going
over and asking what i will do is i will
look at my immediate surroundings and
what people in the immediate
surroundings are just as uncertain as i
am then the problem is that i get a
signal from them that they'll be
standing and waiting and I can
that's where they decided not to help or
they're waiting around and then I will
do nothing and then everybody will do
nothing so what I'm as well I will say
here is that the way in which we
collectively process information by the
signals that we get from others those
are the things that we have to be very
aware of in the modern information age
also because much of the reason that we
do we would be to collectively or in
networks or from signals that we get
from our various networks and from that
perspective that's a particular concern
that we have to worry about so too so to
start answering your question we have to
be aware that there are certain
collective pitfalls that we can make
once we start reasoning together and one
of the big ones is that I'm uncertain as
to what I think other people believe so
instead of actually necessarily checking
because it might be hard I'll make
certain assumptions about that they
would make certain assumptions in the
same way and it would be in a an
unfortunate way get to make assumptions
about each other that would actually
borrows from getting to the correct
answer had we cooperated instead had we
started getting more information have
you started asking each other is that
really your opinion on this issue then
we might actually get into the
collective pitfalls in new and Mary I'm
unfamiliar but in a potentially
devastating waste so don't only ask
yourself what your argument for a
certain stances also ask yourself while
other people should actually follow your
argument so not only what your argument
is but my other should people should
follow it and once you're done with that
then start asking yourself well what
sort of information should I actually
use so I should worry about sources and
agrees my position I should worry about
sources that do not agree to my position
and then I should finally worry about
sources that are neutral as a function
of water I agree people to visit but I
disagree with and then I triangle it and
then I get information now it's going to
be very hard to get out of your office
and out of bed in the morning when you
read the paper like that if you want to
get information enough for you too many
rational decisions but what we need I
gatekeepers and curators of truthful
information and the web can actually
stimulate that if we start triangular
procedures and if we insist not only
that people have positions or stands as
a point of view
get out on Twitter but also why and in
such a way that is transparent what sort
of premises goes into which arguments
that people apparently follow when we uh
sort of think about the state at least
here in the u.s. in terms of uh
encouraging this type of critical
thought understanding logical fallacies
in just everyday arguments realizing the
difference between an explanation for a
belief and a justification for a belief
which are very very different things
it's a pretty sad state of affairs as
far as this goes at least here in the US
and unfortunately it's become very
politicized as I'm sure you know where
there are actually political groups that
are against the type of that taya uh
against the teaching of that type of
critical thought so how how can we push
back against that because if everybody
had I believe this sort of foundation of
critical thinking and epistemology from
a relatively young age we wouldn't have
this constant fear that the uninformed
will decide an election for example that
type of thing but I'm I'm sort of not
particularly optimistic that it's
something we can change in a big way
well basically what as Donald said was
that you have to obey the principle of
non-contradiction you can't just
contradict yourself and still be
meaningful and even to the ones who
maybe post factual about facts they have
to read they have to at least
acknowledge that they can't say it it's
both that and not that and one at the
same time and so from that perspective
it still goes to show that the principle
of non-contradiction is very central to
us even if you argue for a post factual
age if for no other reason that if you
do not accept it then you're not making
one sense one way or the other
independently of who you are so the
principle of non-contradiction is not a
political stance or political project
it's basically a way in which our mind
either understands or does not
understand when you say things are p and
not-p and what at the same time and from
that perspective this has to do with our
foundation of rationality and that has
nothing to do with politics alright
Vincent Hendrix author of info storms
available very very soon this week also
founder
the Center for information and bubble
studies really appreciate speaking with
you today